We've been working so much with inequalities that I'm not sure I even remember
how to solve an equation. You may recall this is an equal sign and when we
isolate x on one side of an equation, we're finding actually a single value that
it's equal to on the other on the other side. Or at least that's what we're
doing as long as there's one number over there. Anyway, just to get our brains
jogging about equations again and to make sure you haven't forgotten everything
you've learned in this class, let's solve this equation. Now before you go
through all the steps of solving this, I'd like you to start by writing the two
fractions on the left hand side of the equation as a single fraction. So find
the common denominator, figure out how that changes the numerators and then
combine like terms.